ryan reynolds is taking a step back from
his red-hot acting career and for a
really good reason yeah so back in
october ryan went on instagram and
announced that he'd be taking a
sabbatical use that specific word for a
while and in a new interview with
lincoln i guess you're talking about
leaving work you do it with linkedin
ryan explained that he wants to be a
more present dad to his three daughters
during this crucial time in their lives
you're embarking on a bit of a
sabbatical you're stepping back from
acting
why well i've done a lot of it uh you
know i'm extremely passionate about
mountain and about maximum effort uh my
company and and it's giving me an
opportunity to
you know
the biggest thing for me and i know that
you have kids as well is that i i i i
want i don't want to miss this time with
my kids as well so uh they go to school
during the day i get to work on mountain
and maximum effort when i'm shooting a
film i'm you know oftentimes i'm in
europe i'm away it's it's they're
incredibly long hours there's a ton of
you know constant kind of uh uh
there's a sort of requirement to be
there the whole time you know just not
just because i'm performing but i'm also
generally producing and writing on my
movies as well so they tend to
chew and blow bubbles with every aspect
of my life when i'm shooting a film
there's a real kind of benefit and
energy into resetting things a little
bit you know for me i just want to live
like a normal human i think i want my
kids to have a pretty normal schedule i
mean for for many years when my wife
blake would shoot a film
i would not shoot a film and i would you
know be the kids and then and vice versa
so we sort of trade off we never really
worked at the same time but always we
were away so the kids were away too now
that they're in school you know they
have they have to have a somewhat normal
schedule i think it's really important
for their development and i i like to i
really enjoy being a present dad i love
taking them to school in the morning i
love picking them up i love that i have
the hours in between to focus on the
things that i'm really passionate about
like mountain and maximum effort and
yeah but it's uh it is a juggling act
and i don't i certainly don't miss zoom
school but you know
no not sure it was it was it was really
lovely to have that insight and
visibility into my kids
real daily
lives and for my wife as well
uh good father good husband amazing
actor what can't he do yeah it's uh and
those are all solid reasons yeah
and i think that the you know when you
talk about what makes it awesome when
you've made it to the sort of levels of
ryan reynolds and other people who have
stepped you know who have stepped back
is that you can do this without fear and
i think that that's the goal for anyone
i think that that's the dream when you
are a parent is you know you would hope
to get to a point of where you could say
i'm going to take my foot off the gas
for a little while and just love all of
this
otherwise what's the point yeah right
well it's interesting because i can't
remember the last time an actor who's at
the height of their career and i mean i
guess you could argue that ryan's been
at the height of his career for several
years now but you come off red known as
the most viewed film on netflix you have
free guide that seemed like it was this
massive surprise hit now you've got a
sequel in the works i mean it was viewed
in theaters as much as superhero films
were viewed especially during a time of
covet i mean he truly does seem like he
is at the height of his career it's like
he can't
he can't
he everything he does is gold so for him
to take a step back now
i mean i hear what you're saying when
actors hit that level that they can do
that and they're not scared but it's
it's a real testament to him and and how
important his family and his daughters
are to him the time that he wants to
take off to be with them i think that's
wonderful and yeah like we said he's not
just the actor he's an executive
producer he has all hands on deck when
it comes to every single project he
works on and you can be a superstar and
not work as much you don't have to work
the amount that dwayne johnson works you
can work the amount that leonardo
dicaprio works that's a good point he's
always working but it doesn't seem like
he's always but he's not cranking out
three films a year right like he's not
you can you know you can still do that
uh but no it's great i i would love i
think that any parent would love to i
shouldn't say any parent there's some
parents with the nightmares to be locked
in the house with the kids
but i i having the choice to do it is is
definitely fantastic and i think his
reasons are you know completely solid
and it's not like working late it's not
working here yeah you know when when the
kids are in school and he's got to be in
europe for three months to shoot a movie
working 13 hours a day
you know you are not present yeah you
can't be that divided it doesn't work
absolutely aj saying when a big actor
like ryan is shooting a movie it's
literally like living a different life
that often doesn't include loved ones
for a long period of time this one's my
favorite because i know you have a
daughter who's going to hit those
teenage years soon paula saying makes
sense that he can go back during the
teenage hormonal age lol wow that's kind
of funny because his kids are still
pretty young
he's going to dip at 11 or 12.
he'll be like no no no they're fighting
back no thank you rebecca's saying i
think he needs to do whatever is best
for him yes and his family which i think
that is so lovely and nicole saying
everyone should be able to take us about
a call at some point in their life yeah
not everybody can so if you can no take
that opportunity because you don't want
to have regrets